you
this is a king of the hill er
a one-minute king of the hill Archon II
I wouldn't be surprised if the if half
of these games were classical played six
games already okay let's go with this
you know what I think might be good
opening the Scandinavian I want this
pawn to be captured
I want my King to have a fast track up
there cuz this guy gets in the way you
know so I would love to see this pawn
captured my King is closer to the center
okay I think that that's a blunder cuz
now I just need to remove the night and
get here or I'm even ready to go here
now
oh maybe did I blunder huh
I just blundered King here would have
been a game over move oh man oh no I got
a stop King here definitely have to stop
that it's a big there's a big battle
going on ah if here I'm gonna take I
think I want to do this just to lure the
King away uh he's a thinking he's a
thinker I think I have this no no I
could just go here next can't stop it
you could always pre move somebody told
me that yeah I think it was in a comment
to one of the YouTube videos you could
always just pre make a pre move of
course towards the center squares we got
the cheddar man the cheddar man made it
the cheddar man was asking for that link
okay um playing with a space
disadvantage and king of the hill is
tricky tough to work around this guy
let's go here alright so this and it
feels like well like it will be a
regular chess game for some time I like
that my king can quickly come up like
this let's just grab some tempos against
the queenie maybe we go in this pawn
yeah why not
how do they defend that how do they
defend it maybe like that
I think this I'd end up in a pretty
nasty pin okay I'm I'm fearing that this
phone will become a liability I could
point f/2 they maybe had an opportunity
for this their King is so far away from
being anywhere close to the center I
guess will double up on the defy let's
support v5 okay there's likely some
tactics brewing around here let's just
trade and sneak in f2 is especially
sensitive I'm not sure where I'm going
with my queen
I guess we'll expand and expand further
I want the g5 square for my queen let's
just take him out get my king up
he needs to get here oh I could just
capture the Queen they're down on time
the Queen I got another game the Queen
the Queen was on D three - four - I'm in
sixth a lot of fire up there
I will hold off on castling okay let me
let me plug this up yeah
I still have to be careful I think I
could take there ah no this is I could
have captured the knight threatening
mate in one
okay we could go not here I would lose
Wow let's just take I don't want this
King getting close let's go here alright
and just stop this King from getting
close I want to flush him away if I can
oh it's easy to lose sight of what the
objective is with this one okay so I
want to get here
good undermined d6 yeah I can look to
take this pawn and then play we got some
discoveries could have some fun with the
discoveries grab a pond give a check
here check there improve the King start
to enter get him out of my house
expand and it's just enter they don't
have
much time guess I can keep pushing with
these guys keep pushing and how is he
gonna be stopped
alright I don't care about that pawn
here here and that's the ball game but
they're down on time back to tournament
okay I see sack of sash sasquatch it's
always I'm always tongue-tied with that
one yeah these guys haven't played much
king of the hill they've gained nearly
400 350 points each
888 four eights adobe flash gambit let's
go with the Scandinavian okay you got to
get chip away at this guy right here
alright pin aroni and then I guess e6
you know when there's instances of fixed
pawns in the center I think it's kind of
tough to get your King towards the
center so quick okay I could take here
and bring the Queen out I guess he's
gonna be stuffing up its castle and I
think I want to go with f6
okay I could take here and here and I
want my King here my king is boxing the
my knight is boxing the king out hmm
let's start with this because I want to
play here
get my king just a hair closer towards
the center my voice is cracking oh I
didn't see that move okay
oh I didn't even see that the Queen's
could be exchanged
it's totally blind to that gotta get my
king to d6 I think and then to e5
that'll be tough to stop no all the
Knights ready to go there but now I have
a quick track making one how do you stop
that Knight has to play there let's get
rid of the knight move the knight and
then go here okay mate next can't stop
King to e5 game over they resigned back
to tournament I got 12 I'm in second
there's 46 in this one alright still 21
minutes to go what's up Romeo in the
chat oceanspud that's a new name I think
hazard let's try a form that's Sicilian
okay let's go with an open Sicilian and
I definitely like f3 here so I might
want to get my King on f2 instead of
castling yeah I'm a fan of this set up
my king is pretty close
I want to Queen trade and then put my
king here 95 right no not not just yet
Knight d4 yeah
it's tough piece to work around oh
that's dropping the farm yeah they
resigned back to tournament their King
wasn't even going to be close
they missed Knight takes Bishop there
that's a full queen
ah let's see
snake chomp hello to you in the chat
alright called us
hmm all right a d4 d5 game
oh okay and try to take advantage of
this pin maybe I think the Queen is well
placed on d6 let's take with the pond
I want to undermine this guy King on FA
probably soon probably soon hmm
all right I want I want to force this
capture um I could take with the Queen
in the rook I have control over this
let's get the King closer push and play
right here my king is getting even
closer
I want to triple up and let's see my
king he only needs to get here could
take what's check first no watch this
move boom boom and then King to e5 I
needed to do those sound effects and I'm
winning with this too
King here the value of the King just a
move away from getting in the center is
enormous that's a win 20 what's fire
okay some crazy crazy ideas for sure
when you're just a step away let's take
that guy out let's keep the king in the
center still
some wild queen sacrifices yeah I'm
gonna creep closer let's get out of the
fin is this a bit too much maybe maybe
five push the night away okay I could
take twice cuz I Knight takes Knight I
have King e for threatening Knight takes
Knight with's check and then King to e4
oh oh I'm on the Queen
I must miss that there's a bishop there
alright let's just take the night they
had bishop they're picking up my queen
and I feel like I still would have had
something so King here cannot be stopped
next move
all right we're not quite at the halfway
point they resigned back to tournament
it's been a while for king of the hill
16 minutes 30 seconds left all right
this king is probably going a bit too
wild there hasn't even been a piece
exchanged and they're not even a pawn
exchanged aces are dragging a little bit
just a bit notice how often I'm moving
my f-pawn so I can have this square for
my king maybe even I could try to
preserve him with h3 okay mm-hmm
oh man I felt like I would be getting
mated somehow if I did this the vh4 here
and then f5 let's get him out of here
I'll take a pond I might be mating
that is not too long off king is one
square away and once again just like huh
I just dropped my queen ah total blind
spot total blind spot
I want this to happen cuz now I could
maybe get to this square off after I
chase the night away or maybe under mine
I could have captured this pawn to its
take and then take again threatening
mate mate doctor tournament don't blink
Romeo's thank you for subscribing with
twitch prime Romeo's appreciate the
support
Wow was that the fries Queen ever close
to it
maybe there's maybe there's some
drawback in king of the hill
in regular chests that is as free queen
is you're gonna see all right yeah hmm
let's take yeah they have this space
over here I don't like that at all
not at all hmm I don't know
get this pawn involved jump in here
that's a check King can't go too far
I'll put some
control these squares I need to get my
king up let's go King I need your help
hmm I think I can't I think I can allow
this pawn to move so easily yeah I
thought you might do that okay
I think I can rely upon my knight to
watch over this square oh man
or not okay wait I could do this here
and then I have to do this I think I
need my pawn to guard these two they're
trying to undermine my pond I think I
could swap off all rooks a King and pawn
ending in king of the hill that might be
a move let's take him out
these guys are forming a wall all right
let's see King and pawn ending its take
am i entering I'm getting this pawn I'm
winning wow I am winning and I'm getting
here next game over
back to tournament oh I think that was
losing
yeah my opponent should have had
something there if they found a couple
accurate moves right there in the middle
game
I was cooked King and pawn it you
definitely don't see that too much not
at all a King and pawn ending like that
and king of the hill I am fine with this
I have a nice grip over efore I may even
be able to bring my king up here but
unlike in that one game I want to make
sure I could secure my Kings post here
so yes let's get no I meant to do each
six first all right not sure how much
time this is really wasting but yeah I
meant have a go h6 first now he is one
step away so this means I could take
here there's already fancy stuff and I
have good enough control over this
square and for as long as there's a pond
here I'm alright so now what they're in
a pen I could go further I'll take with
this pawn because I want to have this
square open for my king hmm now they're
threatening my bishop let's just back
all the way up they don't have much time
yeah my king is rock-solid here King
here next yeah not stopping that I could
take the knight if he went there
all right 36 34 I'm only up to this guy
has only slipped up to me he's been
berserk in ever since he preserved his
second game 3-3 and yeah he's been on a
berserk streak alright let's try maybe
maybe I could try with f4 on move one
let's try Kings gambit why not
Oh some serious weaknesses here grab
some more space I could have also
considered this move right away let's
flush the King back it mic hang up I
feel like this will be a win
take my knight I get this square yeah oh
oh there's Bishop takes pawn here have
to do that
alright well the idea is to get rid of
this Bishop distract the bishop and get
here I don't think it could be stopped
what this might be worth a rook just by
his position alone when he's one move
away and some some way or another right
just a single step away great things
happen yeah space advantage less than 10
seconds it's okay that's clever
alright I guess we'll take here the
Knights gonna go there hmm
yes we take and now I want to get rid of
that that Knights
um I don't know how to get rid of that
night
I'm trying
okay oh man ah my king
help my king out there down on time I
thought it would I thought it would end
like that but they were fighting back I
don't think I was able to get in the
center they were just barely covering
that e4 square that f5 and timely Knight
to f6 I don't think there was a way okay
what do we do against a maximum let's no
let's try the bird 42:39 so that guy
that's in second he slipped up f-4e form
let's pin their night and here we go
very basic plan on an F working on f2
good things happen
now let's get even closer maybe shoo
this night away from controlling these
squares yeah I could go here pawn takes
I just have mate okay that's uh I think
there's something clever here I'll be on
the Queen and then I'll have the e4
square hmm let's keep this guy once
again it's game over if they take here
now I'm threatening King here game over
how do you stop that it's not stopped
you can't stop it that's game over back
to tournament forty-four forty two
thirty less than seven fifty five
players in this one
okay
mm okay okay okay Nick just have a habit
of calling this guy Nick all right I'll
take and then run towards the center
all right let's I need some support I'd
love to see this capture okay I'm
threatening a fork invite my king
forward oh that's a check
careful King be very careful hmm I guess
it's okay to return I want to get here
really really soon all right
oh man I'm spending a lot of time
okay Bishop here I just want my bishop
out I want to get some coordination
I'll just capture this Knight yeah I'm
nervous about I'm too nervous about
taking the knight and giving this square
up I'm even I'm nervous about even
taking here I want to keep this pawn on
this square because I don't worry about
the King getting here I only have to
control this square with pieces wouldn't
mind seeing some trades I'll grab a pond
let's secure my knight
more trades are welcome for sure and I
could go with another trade and how can
I get my king in six seconds
my king up
okay I got it next one move sooner I
instead taking the night ah four minutes
and yeah four minutes on the nose 48:44
that guy has fire that's in second whoo
I think that got a little bit too
complicated more complicated than was
needed
all right so this isn't a good setup I
don't think that
team black is going with this is too
much space my king getting up here and
let's secure this this point I'm gonna
allow that yeah I want some stuff to
open up here okay I'll hold off um how
do we break this down I want it I want
to get rid of these guys maybe this is a
way okay now I could slither in with my
oh I'm threatening mate it's threatening
mate there um let's take let's give a
check then here and I guess get some
development in oh that's not right
I got this square now can't stop it next
move it's game over
King you four he can't control you for
two minutes 28 seconds I don't have a
lead anymore 49 48 I have a lead now not
by much is he in a game we're gonna see
is this a live game or not if we get
paired up it's gonna be for all the
marbles and there's just enough time for
it
54 52 two minutes two seconds I don't
see any moves are we gonna get paired
yes this is for this is for it all oh
man I don't even have any uh I don't
have no no fry tactics available either
I think this game will have to finish
I like seeing that capture can my King
not just uh let's go here I think my
King has a faster track towards the
center No
oh man King right here
you stop that let's take and take here
turning you to push their King back one
minute ten seconds okay here if the
Queen goes away I have check and then
here
get out of there I need this square
that's game over they just took my clean
56:54 did they do that on purpose so
they could try to get in another game
they're in another game 56:54 they could
still get to and he berserk Tazewell oh
no oh I don't know don't win that game
these games could end so fast maybe you
have to try something crazy
I have to try to get to
Center really fast
take
after block and then oh come on right
here just move move move take my night
yes I got the win in KC one did is he
gonna win
no he didn't win but just in case oh he
ended up losing that game I think yeah
he ended up losing that game he berserk
sorry if I got loud there but down to
the while down to the wire
oh man okay 60 54 3432 got a little
confetti there alright let's see the
other pages page 2 3 4 5 & 6
alright to the 55 of you it games all